How is It Goin, Bros!
WELCOME! to a new *hand rainbow* LetsPlay
This one is called finding paradise
if you know right now....  You know. You know what? Pound it. (NobodyPoundiT) That's right. That's right. Ah
????
This is made by the same wonderful guy that made
To The Moon..
To the moon is a game. I played about five years ago five..ve.. five and a half, and it was really this sort of
My youtube thinging I think this is one of the first Let's Plays. I did that waznt a horror game
to the moon of course and
Now here, we are
The soundtrack is amazing already. I don't know what this game is about I just know I
Really want to play this game. I
really want to
relive
Those good old days those 2012 poodiepa days that we all
that we all appreciate like a fine wine
Finest wine said the whiskey that will take her back to manly tears
Are you ready to cry? Are you get ready to feel again?
Very well
Let's begin
Finding parodies Paradiso
This it's made in a RPG maker
Which is also
Classic old-school PewDiePie; I used to play so many of these can go that's that's his name. Let's hear it
That's my man
Oh no, it's a sq-
I forgot his slapstick comedy sense of humor. Thank you for that. Oh my god.
Oh, I remember how funny To The Moon was
One of the characters is just- there he is! It's it. This is a sequel
What the f- Eva? Thank you for censoring it; Christian Let's play here
That's how you keep everyone alive including the squirrel
Oh my god, what voice should I do? "Hope you learned something"
Look sometimes it's either us are them
By keeping ourselves a left now we can be around to stop more self-inflicted credit casualties later later later
Logic
And light enlightening. I'm just doing the same voices
we should be arriving at the patients soon I
Could use a snack before then
Do you mind
Wow only you would pack the glove box full of apple apples
Yeah, well my nephew decorates the Christmas tree with them every year
And then I have to eat and for ages
Appa's and a Christmas tree. Hey, don't you dare say it don't you mean and
No, man
Something happened
In that laughs sumimasen hmm oh
Excuse me
I'm not hungry anymore
So for those of you who that didn't watch or play to the moon
It was basically a story about two scientists that could relive memories
That's why I remember it was a while ago
And these are the scientists and we're going to visit a new patient, so we're probably gonna end up doing the same thing
Well check out this red bag
Why can't we go and work in the easy thing?
Because we are here to visit a dead people not to get ourselves killed
Really, I couldn't have I couldn't tell after the trauma of you driving like a stunt double
I need reading lessons besides we're visiting half-dead people very different things
Yeah, well let's hurry and keep it that way
Are they driving the Back to the Future car Oh yours
Sumimasen I regret this thank you. Let's row
Like a cucumber who says that who says thing if wet nanny
You know cucumber rolls sushi
Yeah, no that's quite a stretch, okay
We're walking am I controlling I am okay hmm, there's a leak in sprinkler everything
Hey now you're a rock star what happened here oh
Wow
Yeah, well it's a damn be
Just like your lame hair look what looks like thanks
Potato but my butt Mawson my booboo so pretty
Yeah, well she also named you Oh
bazinga ah
Don't worry Oh get your bear back actually let me take care of this
Why?
what do you mean where I'm
Telling you, I got this way who helps dr. Watts all the way hey
where
Huh is that also hers never that's man you doofus
Ya dingus
It's the new rebel ducks. It's a new rebel. Doll like three days
The kid gets to get attitude and add don't care and don't care and like wimpy teddy bear say
Oh
Justice is served happiness in the world increased everybody
Neal
What what the show wallop him you did you do what?
What do you mean what?
You just took some kids stole and kicked it into the water. You could get sued for
Yeah, yay
My heroes nip rhymes kid in your face
There's so much stuff
Yes, this is girl and damn duty
get it like a tunic or
a vagina
Kristen Channel, I'm sorry
Jesus dancing I
guess I guess there would be a different different action if
Someone else did it man. We should not face Paul myself so freaking hard man Jebus
how
Jeepers Creepers all right here we go. What do they mean with half dead people what is this a Holloway?
Hello
Beaver this is dr. Rosaline and dr. Watts from Sigmund
You're actually here
Yeah, hope you're on time
Um are you letting us in
I'll wait outside the door for you
What's there, why was there
Did you not feel the blast of ice through the monitor
Well if she's the patient's past, then she's got a dang space. It's not like we're here to lay out a picnic
All right, let's go hello, it's Professor Oak look everyone Dave sure
Hel hello may I help you with something
We can wait till you set that damn bike my bucks carrying comrade
Thanks, brah. You really get me
We shall relate to each other great
Okay
Hey, I'm Dave here to fulfill at someone's dying wish huh?
How do you know?
This is the second time I've seen a visit from your company this week
Who is it this time?
: reached you know of him
the retired pilot, yeah
He lives on top floor very nice go on and give him the happy ending. He deserves probably now, I remember
Didn't they didn't just visit people's memories. It was dying people's memories to give them a fulfilling death
Deep stuff
Man it's so nostalgic to be back playing a game like this I
Mean I I'm told this is as good as the first one spazzes am I right
Always make the job so cumbersome
Depends on the person
Or
Cucumber sim am I right
Doctor Rosaline is it and doctor wet ahead
Yes, we're here, yes, we're here for calling oh of course. Thank you both for coming
Right this way
Okay, let's go everybody
See what's inside?
Oh
What was that was that a little smirky? It's a trap?
Admiral Ackbar do simpie Oh Act one. Tell me what do you want to change? I don't know?
Maybe the voice is
picked
Here we are everybody in the new room with him a new atmosphere very nice
This is a queen. Please see God. He Collins in the other room come with me
Right down to business. I like that
Do you actually?
Yeah, cuz right now. I just really need to put this back Stan. I've been carrying this box forever
You see it's a very heavy box. I could go on about this bucks for a long time you know but not too long
me
Whoa, oh there was a guy there damn, I thought they had like those self opening ones you know never mind
You must be here for my father
Yes
You're the patient son yeah, I came as soon as I here
Where we can talk later?
Why don't you get set up first the box look heavy?
See he gets he gets it
Yes put down that box
Of course where the hell do I pretend this box sorry in here?
Okay
Where are you two going?
Just stretching my links and breaking my back. Sorry why do I hear?
Are you guys ready to get set Oh
Set the Machine down. Yeah, just give us a moment
Yeah, right all right all right, we're gonna enter his mind oh
It's the power here sufficient
Why does everyone keep asking me it'll work fine jeez
But first brace yourself for a power outage of the cinematic proportions
Look at this shit dope right
Hell yeah
Chris and Shannon
Huh, I guess you got more stable paragrah than her headquarters
That's equally comforting as it is worrisome. I am French therefore siblings. You're in good hands. We do this all the time
too much of the time if you ask me
So you two are for real
What do you mean?
So someone's been here before and they failed can you really fulfill his wish?
We'll certainly try our best ma'am
But we always succeed because it would be uh it would only be in his head though
No like he did not like he'd be able to tell the difference I
Can't read anyhow fess up. What is it that he wants?
Yeah, what does he want?
He wouldn't tennis. He said it doesn't affect us, and we have nothing to worry about
Well that sounds legit
Look Matt, that's okay. We'll find out from him soon enough
Isn't it also in the paperwork
yeah, but who reads that Seth not me, I'm
Kidding, I'm kidding dammit
But seriously, where did the fire go it wasn't in the box nope guess I might have left it in the care
All right, I guess we got time while the machine's booting up anyway
Who's gonna fit dr. Watts all the way rock-paper-scissors- lizard-spock?
To decide I'd rather play logic you forgot it so you go get it the end
Did what we're plates back
Hurry are we gonna go I've updated the system. It's practically configuring itself now. Good battle sleep some time
Already down to business, huh?
Hey, I remember you
Yeah, it's me doctor. It's been a wet Stesha Puri this
Although burnt dr. Winters and Dr. Lin assigned to this patient instead
Yeah, but they're roosters are full at a time so we have really hairy hairy egg
here
Heroic Lee volunteered nailed them. I know I'm amazing at reading
Turnout they got nothing to do today, though
Hmm, I guess you never know with the timing no the timing with the nature of your job
Anyhow don't mind me? I'm just gonna check on the patient
Anyhow okay fine by me all right, so
Is it me or is it really laggy?
No it isn't okay, it's there anything I can help with I'm just gonna go. I'm just gonna fuck
Alright let's go
Nia Nia don't forget to get the patient status monitor from the Collins
Medical dark first good idea wouldn't want to be snoozing when he gives the lung now wait what am I doing? Sorry?
Here this should help okay?
Collins heart rate monitor is now activated press escape or right click to open
Trust a little by our listing just hope he doesn't give me tumors
Okay connects wirelessly all right, okay? I don't have anything right now
Jay okay, so something somebody's gonna happen when we go back to the car. You know it fam
Just mark my word. I know everything cuz I'm the smartest on the planet
They sure must be rich to live in a house like this
Didn't I take the elevator yeah, I did okay, man. I can really go walk for
Press Q or miles to switch between characters what?
What
Nia wasn't kidding this thing really is configuring itself
It does that now. Yeah apparently the new ping isn't the only upgrade I?
Guess that means I get some time to snoop around the hairs
Cool in the meantime. I'll go monitor the patient like a real doctor I
Kid I kid
Hey, hey listen here you little
sneaky, bitch I
will fuck you up I
Should go get someone, okay?
Could you show me around yes
Sir the apartment do you mind showing me around the police I prefer to stay here with my husband you dumb bitch oh
Okay, what up what about you?
Anything I could have with dak I
Think you could show me around the apartment while I'm waiting for my colleague of course I can we
Stefano Williger Asha has joined the party patty patty patty very nice at
SAS model of a smurf fix that craft. Oh, this is your dad's it shows
He used to be an airline pilot today. I guess it reminds him of his roots. Ah
That that we got we got a little hint see we got a little hint see everybody what else can be fine
Oh look. It looks seems like an image session
This is my father sold Sheila he played it a lot back in the days
But not anymore it seems maybe because he's dying Rosaleen
Yeah, I guess it's hard in the list too much fapping. He usually just placed the scale style
It's not exactly music to be enjoyed all
Right we got an aged cello
What is that line what is the line oh?
My god, I got a brain fart
Oh, yeah
Little yachties saying blow that dick like a cello
Sorry
Also your fathers or
No, this is my mother's she used to lull me to sleep playing it back in the day
Intense intentionally. I hope I II
Basically lil yachty the rapper confused a cello with a
Oh my god. I can't even speak today a
Flute like Squidward's flute he plays the
What does he play oh my god a
Clarinet Squidward place a clarinet you can't blow a cello everybody and I can't remember words
And he deflected the whole thing. Just type whatever you know what no one cares. It was just funny
this is your parents yeah, that's then I
Remember being embarrassed about that picture as a kid, but it's kind of sweet that they kept it so away
Okay
Oh
Must be hard work growing tropical plants all the way out here
Hey, I wouldn't know any better my mother takes care of them
We had these around the house for as long as I can remember. I guess it's some kind of family tradition a
viscous
Hibiscus hibiscus
Can we can we swap character by the way ah you can?
Where did they go where did they go where'd it? Okay? All right? Well let's
Why not?
We have the option. That's pretty cool
So while here I'd say love it would switch to the other character
No, nevermind. I
Tried to innovate. Okay, okay, it scares me
I'm just gonna go get the duck
Donna ready, you didn't die on you did he Jesus
No, no sheesh who hired you
Professor Oak
Dave what a name what's your name Dave Yeah, right? What's your real name? It's Dave. I swear. It's my
My name is Dave. It's a real name. You know
So we're at a hospital. I didn't realize I thought it we were at someone's house. I'm an idiot who's dying dear
Excuse me ma'am
that curtain tag you are from segment if
You're here, then someone's time's up
Coleen reads do you know him I see?
He and his wife your sister all with my husband and me here everyday, please do your best for him dare
You sound awfully calm about it if I were your friend. I'd be worried
After years of seeing everyone around you go. It's hard not to be
But dead you of all people should know that well
Excellent it's been great talking to you. I'm gonna go now
Where's the car there's a ramp you didn't see the ramp silly me I
Hope we take the motorbike later. I hope something happens with the motorbike
Are you kidding me?
Open the there we go. Thank you thought it was in the trunk for some reason
It's happening a
Lot of the soundtrack is so nostalgic to the to the moon
Dagnabbit did I leave it at the office. I better take this mother back to get there quicker
Are we calling the office
Hello
Roxas me new still adding your caller ID yeah
Get it under 10 getting calls from unknown feels like I'm in a horror movie. You know
My bet I'll turn it up next time
No, I know this is fast
Every day every time I'm like am I getting cursed are the feds coming after me the excitement's are and lives
um
Alrighty, anyways look. Are you still at the office? I think I left the patient spell on the printer. Oh?
okey-dokey
Pokey loci, just give me a moment
Hey hey you got the file
Even I think it, I think I forgot it backache you
know fuck
Don't worry. I can't read say she's gonna find it and send over a scam
Ok just take care of it
Wow
This job is really busting my Nets. Did you find it Rex?
Yeah, it was just sitting on your table after all
Great just scan it and wait my table. You're in my room
Yep, you asked me to get the files right I
Meant from the printer in the lobby how did you get in my room? Anyhow? I locked it. Oh a girl's got her ways
Okay look just get out of there and find a scam, would you and don't touch anything? I just organized it
Yep, be up on it
She's not gonna leave
You Rach
What
Oh my god!
Vishnu God is always my dad. Oh my god. Oh
Your guys got everything else you need yeah, if it's configuring the machine baton hey
How's the weather out there? What is it nice out for a drive? I?
Guess Civ
Neato, I think I'll just come over and get you the file in person then
What why?
Just scan it and send over a copy well. We've got no patience today, and it's boring here anyway
Anyhow don't worry. I'll get there before you guys are done. See ya after him wait Rox
Dagnabbit
That's what I should have said damn it
If only I had a broader vocabulary things would be different hey, we're here now DAG nabbit
You guys see that cliff we post him alone
Never mind then damn dang it why is the toilet people never on the dispenser?
marzia, never puts it on the dispenser, and I hope she hears me I
mean I
I'm gonna die
One day they'll thank me for the unsung hero, but I am I'm thinking you know Rosaline
I salute you put the damn toilet paper where it belongs
I'm not some animal
Wow this is truly an immersion of experience
We're putting toilet paper. Oh, we're back here
All right, I think we're done
Yes
About Kahn do you mind telling me about your husband? Why won't you be going into his head to see for yourself?
But well we're background the perspective could always help. I don't know what I could tell you that you won't be able to see
How does she know it's not like she knows what it's like if they had this equipment
I'd be like what are you seeing here? Huh?
You okay Edgar? Am I waking you up am I too loud for you?
Yeah, shut the hell up roach. I hear sleeping on my lap so
cute
All right, let's go upstairs because we haven't done that
and let me talk a little less loud for a jacket I
Haven't seen many apartment with multiple floors
Most of the flow is for maintenance we just go got a little storage um cadet
Sorry about the mess seems like they'd been doing doing a bit of clean happy
What sorry about the mess seems like they should have done some cleaning? Huh seems like the missed one I?
Think I reckon I said bicker it's been around for quite a while
My dad kept it taped up. I guess it didn't want to throw it away
Mysterious book
Yeah, it's seal but
He doesn't want anybody reading in her it must be his diary
Well under normal circumstances. I'd say leave it alone for privacy sake but he did sign up to become your claim
So I don't know
Hell yeah, let's read that shit dog there was a chance that he might help the mission
There's nothing in this, huh
It's nothing but stacks of empty pages glued to the spine
What that makes no sense?
What?
there won't wrinkle -
That's right
It's been around for a gesture. Maybe whatever was under faded
These aren't receipts, but I guess it's possible
Either way there's not much I can do with this
I'll put it back. Let's keep moving
All right
Very good. Oh, Oh actually there is something else that might help you prepare, ooh
Oh
What is it?
Yeah, the family photo album kiss my back a
Physical photo album in this day and age feels like it turn to - if I open it
It's great
but I guess they liked having something they can catch a a
Look through it if you want. I go check on my father I
Should go get the Machine ready - my colleague will be back soon
But I'll check this app for a bit first
Very well, they will go
sayona
arrivederci
goodbye, I
Look at these pictures
That's adorable oh
That's so sweet
Cabaye Disney
So they played together instruments wonderful
Dr.. Watson
How are we doing? He?
Good got my partner
How about the file you said Brock's is slimming the schemes?
She said she's delivering it in person for some reason
That's wasting both of our time and hers
Hers mostly Harwich Mosely we can still stack
still I mean how I know she's a bit cucumbers in the hand and oh
Wow, what a what a wonderful way to say someone is an idiot
Whoa language even
Anyway, don't worry about her looping this later. Shall we start
All right, I read that wrong just get the patient equipment
I
Knew hmm
Never mind we'll talk later
Your helmet is on the requirement. We're all set we're gonna go inside
We're gonna go inside boys Hayley Virtual Reality
Commence memory traversal ready
Wait aspetta!
Before you begin could you tell me what your you'll be doing in there?
We're going through his memories to grant him his last wish death I
Thought you knew
Yes, I do know that but
Yeah!!
What would you actually be doing?
Well
No time to explain
Look although your father's condition is stable for now. He is an attainment I
Can't say for certain, but we have about a day's time to work with
Sorry I didn't mean to hold you hit. I don't know what's going to happen in there, but good luck
Luck's for Lawry's we're professionals
Ish a twig kitchen see you in the other side
See I should have done all the sudden sound effects patient is stable and ready
initializing memory traversal sequence in three two one
Yep pretty good pretty good sound effect. Thank you. Oh
We entering the first memory oh yeah, there was a timeline oh
All right, this could be callings last accessible memory
Yeah, and check out if the reigning heavy sleeper Champa check out the ring heavy sleeper jab over here
Leave that memory of her alone, she's not our client by the way, I want to ask earlier
What's with the helm you put on your our patient?
Hmm the equipment it looked different oh, I just removed it casing during maintenance, that's all
Then why didn't you put it back hey that reminds me did
You know I added a new feature
new feature
Be her
Never mind forget I asked
Character customization Wow
What why??
Tomato I can't even see them - made a pattern
That can only be one yes
Just why well I figured if we're gonna spend so much time break-in here, we might as well travel instead
We did I say we sorry I meant oh wait. That's exactly what I mean
Dad you're it
Cucumber oh
My man you had long flowing locks well not any merit
That's not too bad none of these are bad. Yes
Hey don't blame me. It's a system that choose it for you
Are they talking about me right now?
Well the system is it down to me. You know hey hey I can hear you
Well well don't insult the system. That's not cool
Whatever, I'm changing back oh
Come on. It was a lot of work to implement
Besides you owe me for what happened at the tofu party last night humor me for a bit
You did take a solid hit for me at the toefl party
Fine I'll keep the look until we find : sue a nice sex by the way yeah, I'm okay with the shocks
All right current memory position in time can be viewed by moving the mouse forward at the top of the screen okay, Oh
What's turnoff world interaction before we wake around
Okay after all that I'm surprised we didn't already
What I don't remember this
Okay, we're we're fading back in goddamn. She's sleeping hard dog
What knocked her out?
It's not polite to stare Shh, and she didn't seem to like us before
Where do we go? I don't know I don't remember like where you're supposed to do
Your kid gay
Oh here we go. Oh there is isn't gonna add a skin calling. Oh
What this is an astable copy let's find one we can talk to?
What
Does I mean we have to find another version of inside. Oh there we go okay
Man, I'm too good at video games
honestly
You are lucky. You're watching the best. Let's player on YouTube without a shadow of a damped
Should we go up sir yeah? It must be upstairs. Maybe working on the book
watch me be right watch me be right look at this 10 out of 10 where I shit I
Will sometimes you're unlucky and it happens to everyone
One moment let me just check the book chains
How did I pass out that I thought bad about that huh? Oh now?
We can read the book. It's still full of books here. You must have cleared it very recently then
Get it
Yeah, well I checked this place in reality. It was empty except for one Outlook
Which isn't here actually Oh?
speak
Okay interesting
So, maybe we should recheck some of the memories like the flower perhaps
See see if there's anything nope nothing. Okay. Well let's let's exit here then
Nothing more to do here, I suppose
Whoa edger ah
Pretty sure the hole didn't look like this
Dude, dude, so old. He can't even remember his own hand but
Isn't the machine supposed to autocorrect these kind of spatial inconsistencies? Yes, of course?
Well oh
Hey, look, hahaha
What is happening dude
Didn't the whole me look like this I remember it like this
Target acquired let's go bazinga. Ah I thought you forgot
Him all right
Thanks
turning on entity interaction I
Think let's go full-on attack
Pokeball go I do remember there was like poke balls in the first one
Colin
Jesus...
What up??
My name is dr. Emma Rosaline. I am a memory traveler soul specialist at segment Corp
And my colleague here is dr. A headband
Doctor man
You are dr. Neil watts. How did you know your nametag? Uh??
This isn't what it looks to be is it
Yes calling your procedure has started good. It's not just me then
Something felt off about this place. It's as if I'm both here and far away at once
Either this is where I think I am or my head is going down here faster than I thought
More like both actually Hey Farren it
My wife and son how are they handling it? They're there right there there, right?
Yeah, but they aren't prancing around that's for sure although given the circumstances I guess I'd be worried if they were
Listen there's not a lot of time and it's best if we get started
You are the most recent slice of calling that we can load up and
the only relatively reliable version that we can interact with for info
So I hope you can exist us in completing the mission of course. Why would I nee?
Good, i'll keep your state saved so we don't need to have this conversation again
just
Let us save on this day
Yes your highness
Now in order to help you relive your life here's
here to fulfill your last wish
we are gonna backtrack through your marriage to connect your Tamlyn and
And then we'll be able to transfer your desire all the way to your doom yourself
And run the algorithm for you to live your life here all over again to fulfill your wish
Anyhow calling we need your help
To jump between memories we need mementos
There are the items of importance that you connect from memory with another?
Do you have one here that we could jump with?
Well well slow dad. We still don't even know what his wish is
what is it that you aren't anyway :
Actually, I think I can answer both of your questions with this
It's his Sigmund contract the Texas rather blurry but o
It is a momentum sweat, it's ma'am
Well fish moment--just berry or shadows by itself since its so reason, but the next one won't be so easy
Only to charge I it up first okay?
Oh, yeah, I remember this is puzzle bit memories go the far. There's one linked together
All right what
Did I do it her oh I did it everyone
All right, thanks, we might come back for your help again
Okay, what was in the momentum? What is his story? Why does he want?
Don't worry
Wait a minute this place
It's a Sigmund's guesthouse ah
Where they wine and dine the geezer into signing up for this service
Where they wine and dine the geezers in signing up for this service?
Sure been awhile since I visited
Looks a bit different for when I was last here - let's check it out
Requires one memory orb to proceed okay, I guess we can find that
Sorry how
What oh, okay, oh, okay, okay, okay? We go here. I didn't see it. I'm stupid
What are you doing outside in the cold mr.. Reid's your appointment is about ready?
Please right this way. Hey, we got an orb everybody look at that. That is a nice orb everybody
Hey we enter before him what a loser
Welcome to Sigmund Corp Guest House, please have a seat in our living room ow
We detected a memento oh
We got to charge it
Are we good to go?
Why don't you sit back and enjoy some tea first you come a long way to get here? I?
Need to get back home soon. I just like to inquire about your service
Very wet someone will be here to get you very shortly
There's so much to the world isn't there much more than one could explore in one single lifetime
Say would it be nice to visit where you always wanted to go
I've already been there once you put it down yeah another momento cacao
You know I've been rather impressed
laughs oh
Well back in the days. You kept on yelling dumb juvenile ADIZ when shooting the barrels
But recently
Or. What night it's been rather Pleasant and professional, Oh hmm I?
Like how I did it instead great all right. We're looking for one more
This photo is taken from this stage perspective
Accelerating huh not many people get to experience what it's like to be famous
We sure get a lot of requests for that so if it floats your boat can consider it done
Oh, we'll see oh so they can make anything happen I see by the way being famous
means fuck-all
It's an illusion
Depicted by the media that it's something great. It's fucking not there's nothing great about it
If we don't do another one of these I'm gonna take a nap
It's not so bad. At least we get it done fast and go home early
Come on we got to find one more up the stairs
Give us the momentum you
See our service is quite simple you
Tell us your wish and we make it happen fame wealth own reach goals and secret desires you name it
Rear, Jenny Colin. What is your wish?
So if I understand this correctly
You're saying I can't wish for more wishes
You know I've done and seen a lot in my lifetime
I've been to where I once thought I'd never be seeing what I once thought I'd never see
But in the blink of an eye suddenly, there's no more tape
and
I find myself here, just like everyone else I
Walk through these doors, and I realized that there's still this empty feeling inside me
I don't mean to be ungrateful to the life. I had but I
just want to feel like I've done enough in this world before I go you know I
Want to say I lived a happy life, and I want to feel like I have few regrets
But somehow after all that I still can't
That's why we're here Colin
Just give us a word, and we'll make it rain
Tell us your regret. What is it you want us to fix?
regrets I
Don't know what to tell you for the regrets, but I can tell you what I want a
Lot of skittles I never had enough skittles, I just want you to make me live that fulfilling life. I want it
But I want you to do it without changing anything. I've been through what?
Collin you're being way too complicated you don't want us to change anything calling changing things is what we do
We change things and we make them better. That's why you come to us, so we can make it better
We can solve your problems everything you wanted, but couldn't have in this life. We can give you a chance to get it
But if you want to get something you need to give up something so I ask again, what is your last wish
Very well
I
Want you to give me a fulfilling life while changing as little as possible, and if you have to change something?
Please just keep the memories of the life my with my family intact
So you want to wave specifically from the contract
With something like that I hope you know there are no guarantees of result I'm aware
It's settled then I'll put our best people on it, thank you that's all I ask
What do you mean that's all you ask Jesus
Try not to change anything, and we are free raining with his feet
What kind of last wish is that? I don't even know where to start?
hey wave severs the
Important thing here is that the boss said we'll put our best people on it
We're their best people ever
Actually
Nevermind
Ok I'm good. Let's get the momentum all right. Oh one more thing, please
Don't tell my family I don't want to think I'm not content with how things are
Well mission failed
Alright, let's break this momentum kamehameha
Another one of these
Sometimes only the Kurama mentor rings about what?
There you go, it's a clam
Okay climb it up, buddy I
Better get that I better head out before I forget
Yeah, take the side pups it's a hat
With a headache you've been getting you should be more careful of the wind I
Had been telling him that for ages. He never listens all right all right. I'll wear it. If it stops this multi-directional nagging
Look at me. I'm a fricking pimp with his shit on dawg. Hey, it's been a while since your thing with Pam didn't work out
Listen I was talking with my ol colleague the other day. He's he's got a daughter named Janice. You're saying
She's single in look thanks, but I think I just really need to focus and Mecca here. I got this new accent
Okay, came out of nowhere, so you guys gonna go back to feeding the ducks or something
well you wouldn't have to resort to that if you visit us more often your little bastard ah
But that had this 100 percent cotton well all right you're off the hog
Drive safe dear. We'll stay here and keep being overlord of the Ducks
Bimah bimah and plight of you not for the duck thing
But but like you know what they mean what the hell is with the docs
Don't stay out too long at this time of year
That kid needs to make us a grandchild
What's wrong with Jenny anyway?
Probably nothing, but you know how it is when you were young didn't your parents try to push people unto you
Sure, did it was awkwardly it was awkward and forced hmm sucked all the chemistry out of it for me as well
What are you doing I'm texting Jenny's name photoset Timo's don't do that
He's driving do it after he gets out good cop
Make sure to include some pictures too, she has a nice rack the good ones wood lining coming from this side
No words
There we go, okay gonna do a save there
Really enjoy being back in to the moon extremely nostalgic. I hope you guys enjoy it as well
Please do leave a like if you want more. Let me know if you want more. I would love to keep playing this and
Yeah, if so, I'll see you tomorrow
Stay awesome breasts